assez lourd et si oui comment vous allez
vous tout d'abord je m'en fous je m'en
fous je vais garder ce gimmick pendant
toutes les vidéos j'adore aujourd'hui
nous allons tourner une vidéo sur le
thème d'halloween
j'en fais pas souvent des vidéos sur le
thème d'halloween peut-être c'est faux
si c'était faux clément aura mis toutes
les images qui contredit ce que je viens
dire à l'écran et vous savez la
meilleure chose à faire halloween c'est
pas des bonbons à des enfants c'est de
fabriquer satgé plein coeur j'ai aucune
idée de comment on dit ça mais en
français ça c'était si troublante et une
jack o'lantern en gros c'est us culte
dans ta citrouille tulle à vide et tu
fais des trous et vous avez à l'arrivée
des fois tu mets une petite bougie
dedans et ça fait un peu peur non ça
fait peur qu'à moi ça a pas l'air très
complexe à faire et tant mieux parce
qu'après avoir foiré complètement ma
poterie ça me ferait du bien de réussir
nouvelles activités manuelles
ah oui ah oui ah oui tout d'abord
regardons ce que c'est qu'une jack o
lantern et regardez ce que c'est le
travail de gens talentueux qui essaient
de faire des commentaires
ça n'aura rien à voir avec ce que je
vais faire voilà c'est tout ça commence
ça quand ça me fait déjà rire c'est une
sculpture hockey s'est sculpté dans un
truc qui dure il a reproduit
l'élasticité de la peau c'est sympa mais
pourquoi je vous montre des gens trop
fort avant de faire mon truc si nul je
devrais faire l' inverse le raid faut
qu'on travaille un peu le déroulé des
vidéos aux mecs c'est trop c'est une
citrouille ça c'est pas une imprimante
3d gafsa c'est un mec avec ses mains
c'est vraiment à ya un concept d'une
fraise tagada dans une citrouille
semaine alors c'est pas ça une pastèque
le mec s'est dit c'est trop facile de
sculpter une citrouille je discutais
dans une pastèque il ya plus d'eau c'est
plus dur de faire des tris droit ça me
convient mieux
[Musique]
adam et là je suis pas en train qui fait
énormément la phase ont regardé des
vidéos on kiffe un peu je suis même pas
en train qui fait ça me fait angoisses
et là c'est tellement forte hausse elle
est géniale voyez là j'apprécie parce
que c'est pas genre dur à faire mais
c'est l'idée qui fait que ces stylos mec
trop fort annonce assez fou mais comme
ça en pleine lumière on comprend pas
trop ce que c'est mais par contre quand
on éteint la lumière et qu'on met de la
lumière dans la citrouille il ya un
[ __ ] de léopard qui apparaît mec mais
là c'est je pense assez de level max de
la citrouille par exemple je pense
c'était frustrant de regarder des mecs
100 fois plus fort que laura mais je
réussis à ça ça ça va être la même mais
qu on va se contenter de ça bon voilà
bref vous avez compris un peu ce qu'il
est possible de faire avec une
citrouille sa part y compris les
antilles mais j'ai relevé des petites
vidéos tuto évidemment la première étape
c'est de vider sa citrouille pour que
dedans ce soit vide voilà c'est pour ça
que je vois des vidéos tuto mais que je
suis les tutos et voilà on en est là à
2019 je suis assis par terre dans mon
bureau pour découper de citrouille quel
destin funeste donc comme je voulais
dire étape une s'est vidé la citrouille
en minimes et ceux qui font ça à sperone
entre marine que j'ai un couteau attend
le mec il faut 5 outils pour vider une
citrouille
moi je vais le prouver qu'elle a tort de
passer les puristes eric roy faut trop
de trucs et tout mais qu'il faut le
faire
ça va être là au retour temps ok donc en
gros il faut trouver cette partie là
faire un cercle assez large pour pouvoir
il passait la main ensuite c'est super
ce grand show c'est la plus dangereuse
des activités manuelles s'il vous plaît
ne faites pas ça seul chez vous en fait
quand j'étais plus jeune c'est une vraie
histoire j'ai mis mon père aussi père
dont je veux m
partie des gt la mecque j'ai été pris
d'un élan de folie assez comme ça comme
une citrouille et des pépins et tout
mais oui en fait c'est complètement
logique mais comme j'ai jamais fait je
le vois pas prendre ma vie de mes
propres yeux alors chez un peu
stupéfaits mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça lucas salaires appétissant tu ne
manges pas la citrouille natsu alors
attendez l'eiger sur mon père il faisait
exactement ce que j'étais en train de
faire là mais c'était pour ouvrir un
paquet de glace de glaces magnum je me
souviens il fait ça là comme ça tu sais
la boîte c'est vraiment très fermé et là
d'un coup il ya plus récentes et les
couteaux il fait chaque de couteau fait
schlak mec et le couteau était dans le
bras de mon père la lame était dans son
bras vraiment et moi je vois ça je fais
aulas mais c'est grave ce qui se passe
et mon père et fait maintenant
t'inquiète ça arrive on va mettre sous
l'eau il s'évanouit le conte est
heureusement ma belle-mère est venu pour
l'aider mais l'erreur fait le mâle alpha
mais si tu n'es pas mal alpha thierry tu
n'es pas un mâle alpha tuer comme ton
fils
un mâle bêta c'est tout allait bref on
attend donc là il faut y aller à
l'accueillir pour vous tirer tout
l'intérieur a jugé ce bar de l'intérieur
combien de siècles les mecs c'est je
peux pas faire ça mais j'avais comment
je vais faire
[Musique]
non j'en ai marre c'est le pire truc à
toucher donc tous les jours là où tu
mets ta main dans une boîte et c'est
parce qu'il ya dedans il faut deviner
mais tesla [ __ ] mais tu es l'intérieur
d'une citrouille
c'est dégueulasse mais high five tu
goûtes est notre attention
pire odeur du monde
même pas en rêve je goûte sa non boisé
mais franchement je n'ai à peu près vide
et il reste quelques trucs on va pas
chipoter
je me lève la main et on passe à l'étape
qui nous intéresse ok bon c'est le
moment alors c'est quoi la suite à toi
et à 30 secondes la de ce tuto 26
secondes de ce tuto ça a duré 15 minutes
pour moi je veux faire je veux ce petit
outil mais c'est trop bien
du coup c'est trop maniable pour faire
tes lettres et tout découragé j'ai plus
envie je vais pas vous mentir j'ai vu
une citrouille sur wikipédia que je
trouve trop bien je fais copié wikipédia
celle là je la trouve vraiment stylé
j'aimerais vous entendre dire mais
malheureusement c'est une vidéo et par
live ya une étape où je dois dessinée
vous savez ce que c'est le dessin pour
vous avez bien un problème
donc en fait là je dois dessiné sur la
citrouille engrangé faire les traits que
je vais découper ensuite comme un
chirurgien finalement je suis le
chirurgien de cette citrouille
mais ça va être bien toujours ça va être
bien haut
là
ok est ce que tout le monde est prêt
voici le visage de notre première citron
[Musique]
je sais comme chaque création manuelle
que j'ai fait dans les vidéos on dirait
que c'est un enfant de huit ans qu'il a
fait mais non c'est la malédiction de ma
vie andré une fois que râler tout et
qu'on va mettre la merde dans je pense
ça peut rendre cool tour en un peu cool
à base de mousse et dans le noir et que
c'est aimer la lumière et qui est une
lumière ça va être sympa je pense quoi
qu'il en soit c'est le moment où je dois
à découper au couteau alors on va
commencer par le sourcil le problème
c'est que moi j'ai pas son petit outil
nawel fais moi j'ai un gros couteau mec
si je finis semblait sur cette vidéo
c'est dur
ah [ __ ] mec
ok j'ai fait un sourcil ok j'ai raté par
la page vers taper sur six pas non mais
attends plus des stylos médias je suis
gérone à l'institut de beauté là en fait
à et voilà vous / 6 / fait monsieur
voilà en tout cas c'est assez marrant à
faire au final up là-haut retire ça
comme une disquette en 1998 et on a une
deuxième source il
pour le moment elle est pas mal mais les
cieux mec je m'attaque au 1er c'est
parti
[Musique]
ça s'est mal passé mais comment ils font
sur la photo wikipedia pour avoir un
rond comment ils font pareil je vais
vous dire si vous avez des enfants et
vous regardez cette vidéo franchement
faites le avec vos enfants alors je suis
content mais en fait le vous et vos
enfants ils vous regardent mais jamais
vous donnez le couteau dans les mains de
votre enfant est évidemment mais moi
j'ai pas l'âge pour à faire ça en vrai
hockey launay là je sais qu'un axe ou de
ma gueule j'aimerais bien voir le nombre
de gens là comme on va être en allumer à
mettre la petite bougie dont j'aimerais
bien savoir le nombre de gens qui vont
courir entre faut pour acheter une
citrouille a le nez c'est fait [ __ ]
non j'avais oublié que je vais fait des
tonnes en même temps mais que je vais
faire une citrouille sentant elle ferait
pas peur du tout ah mais non en fait
faut que je commence par les dents et
ensuite je fais tourner la bouche et
tout va tomber nikkei tout est lui même
[Musique]
et de rue mais non mais attends j'ai
fait l'inversé de ce qu'il faut faire
mais j'ai un cui mec je viens de tes
jeunes dans là où normalement il ne pas
avoir à tout mais devrait avoir la
citrouille sur un connard
[Musique]
en fait là j'ai découpé tout le tour des
dents et ensuite toute la partie vous
voyez qu'à l'intérieur de la forme
qu'elle a elle va partir et restera plus
que les dents si j'ai réussi dont le
trou au dessus en fait comme ça je peux
pousser de l'interroger pousse pousse
pousse pousse il a déclaré le co je vois
vous commencez à prendre votre tour un
peu hautain je sais ça ressemble à rien
mais je pense que si on est la petite
bougie à l'intérieur surprise
voici la fosse bouge et qu'on va mettre
à l'intérieur quoi ça change de couleurs
justes et pourquoi j'ai acheté ça moi je
pensais que c'était vous allez faut se
bouger qui a des fois au restaurant il
ya de la lumière c'est dans un pot est
en fait de danse pannerie bouger c'est
un truc comme ça et la lumière varient
pour telle option qui est une vraie
flammes mais la juste la couleur change
ça marche pas du tout aller oui oui on a
pas qu'une
je vais là fermés pour pâques et de
fuites de lumière et je vais la pause
est là et on va éteindre toutes les
lumières et on va voir ce qui se passe
bon excusez moi je m'assois sur tes
potes désolé je sais de jours elle et
mes gars c'est pas le résultat de jour
qui compte c'est le résultat de nu ça va
toi et c'est le but d'une citrouille
d'halloween on est dans l'ambiance d'arc
et ces personnes regardent les
citrouilles quand il fait chaud on les
regarde que quand il fait nuit quelle
est la lumière qui viennent intérieur
donc messieurs dames en tenant compte de
ce que je viens de dire je vous laisse
admirer le résultat de cette citrouille
de nuit
gg squeeze une fois de plus est un
véritable désastre
je suis gentil drum and bass weezy
n'oubliez pas de vous
eh bien écoutez c'est la fin de cette
activité manuelle je pense qu'elle fait
partie de l'une de mes préférées avec la
poterie étrangement est ce que ça vous a
plu
oui non faites le moi savoir par
courrier postal par exemple en tout cas
moi j'ai découvert badge à la citrouille
c'est bizarre ce que je dis mais george
avait jamais dû couper de citrouilles
j'avais jamais checker l'intérêt d'une
citrouille et où donc voilà c'est qu'au
petit disclaimer évidemment si vous êtes
jeune et que vous voulez faire ça faites
le avec vos parents fait ça en toute
sécurité
franchement c'est vraiment de marans et
ludiques comme activité je pensais pas
que j'allais autant m'éclater genre
activités manuelles cool affaire à
plusieurs franchement c'est vraiment
cool et surtout c'est utile genre ça
vous fera de la déco pendant la période
d'halloween c'est franchement sympa je
parle d'un truc que tout le monde peut
depuis des décennies comme si c'était
jean révolutionnaire mais je viens de
découvrir big up à tous ceux qui font ça
depuis des années je vous comprends
maintenant c'est bon allez à bientôt une
prochaine vidéo peut-être que le jour
d'halloween on peut se faire inscrire
d'horreur particulièrement flippant
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est une belle
occasion donc satie lisant jeu politique
[Musique]